les gars, nous manquons tous de quelque chose dans le
domaine de la romance
mm-hmm ouais règle un corrige nos
vies romantiques règle numéro deux nous soutenons nos
camarades femmes et nous ne nous laisserons pas nous en
sortir avec notre merde habituelle
ai-je raison mesdames nous sommes  utiliser les
gars de la fête pour séduire un nouveau gars
wow tu dois sacrifier une vierge ou
quelque chose non ne t'inquiète pas tu es en sécurité
le gars que tu cherches pourrait
être juste sous ton huître
je veux dire que c'est un beau moment pour être en
vie  mesdames ai-je raison
oh mon dieu oui
mesdames ces lunettes de rasoir les filles
[Musique]
vous gouvernent